I'm so excited to be sitting here with
one of the funniest comedian actors and
one of my best friends Paul Scheer thank
you so much for having me that bit has
to be here do we shake have clothes no
guy is our hand I'm good for gather our
hand to the other hand speed I believe
that you and I are like slight
variations of the same person I agree
with that I remember when I was really
into cool punk rock music like no doubt
and hey what can I throw something your
way yeah I like no doubt more this is
strange because I find Gwen Stefani
attractive well I think that's part of
the whole thing wasn't that crazy I
think it's weird like that song
underneath it all yeah that song but
then I saw the video she's just jumping
on a bed in like a white undershirt that
song comes on I'm like everyone shut up
I saw them at SNL is my first SNL that
ever went to and Chevy Chase was like
one of the guests on the show
and he was obsessed with getting his
kids no doubt autographs
oh and so like they brought over a
picture like a sign no doubt picture
he's like you spelled my goddamn kids
name wrong and he grabbed this interns
arm pulled it out like I do it to your
arm here pull this I'm like look and he
took him markings like that root on her
arm like that's my kid's name ever do it
again with that name oh my god and it
was I remember standing there into the
first time I've met Chevy Chase now I
know that he's a colossal dick you know
but but back then I was like you're I
got that Chevy Chase what that Chevy
Chase colossal dick I wanted we should
get that into the legs of a guy yeah if
you're a big dick call me Jimmy
there's many a mean story of Chevy Chase
and Who am I to judge I saw two oh I
actually know three or one he was mean
to my mom okay it's weird that you
didn't open with that yeah I just
remembered that Chevy Chase was mean to
your mom yeah my mom was in a liquor
store in New York she's like oh my god
Chevy Chase I am such a fan of you and
go you lady shut yeah
off you lady and my mom came home like a
broken woman like what did I do to this
man like I didn't even say like it I was
like you you have to be remembering it
wrong she's like no that was the oh look
he wrote it on my arm
so some slap rob huebel in the face you
saw him slap rob huebel in the face in
the face we were backstage at UCB that
brought Citizens Brigade doing a scat he
was the guest monologist and he was kind
of hanging out with us and again I put
away that he cursed out my mom I put
away that he wrote a thing on an interns
arm in Shar penis I want my flesh Robert
hey Chevy I'm such a fan nice to meet
you
Chevy Chase just BAM slap them across
the face with no provocation provocation
and everything as hard as he hit it like
that's too hard
yeah and was like I think in his mind
was that's a bit that's what you guys do
at UCB you do bits that's my bit slap
you in the photo No
so I don't think it was not with malice
but that also goes like oh you've been
in comedy a long time you know that's
not a bit you're not gonna slap people
in the face yeah